All right now. Well, welcome everybody for another Zoom call and we are going to talk about some
questions that came in first and we'll put it up for questions. So let's go right to that.
One question that was on the board and also came in about pulsing supplements. So what is pulsing
supplements? Those are medications. So when you're going to do something in a pulse method,
that means you're going to be on for a period of time and offer a period of time.
And there is, it has been talked in the last couple of years that there could be benefit to
pulsing certain supplements. I would agree with that completely. As a matter of fact, I had Dr.
Kelly when she was in the office with us do a seminar or a little video on this a number of
months ago. We did post it on the Facebook page. So please look at that. Or I think we post link to it.
But you can find it on our YouTube account if you put in the question error thing about pulsing
supplements, Dr. Kelly. And you'll see it. There can be benefits to pulsing certain supplements.
There can be benefits to only utilizing certain supplements when you need them also. But when we talk
about cancer patients, is it right to pulse your supplements that are treating necessarily
or you're using specifically to help knock down the cancer? I believe is you don't have to.
So I don't think that you need to do that. I don't think that that in itself is going to make
the cancer by you pulsing it or not pulsing it's going to make the cancer
less resistance to developing an inability towards the supplement. So I don't think that's going to
make a difference. Some of the other some of the detox supplements I think there can be benefit to
pulsing those. It depends on where you're at with your with your care though. So everybody's so
different with that that I would never say that everybody should be pulsing their supplements.
But I would never say that some people would have benefit from doing so.
I personally pulse my supplements but not on purpose.
Meaning there's some days I wake up and I'm really busy in the morning. I forget to take my supplements
in the morning and then I might forget at the afternoon if I get home and I have to cut grass
or do something like that. And it's almost always on days that I'm feeling really well. So if
I'm reminded of my symptoms. So I have a lot of pain in my abdominal cavity which is where
the majority of my pain is that that will remind me to take my supplements. But typically if I'm
really busy there can be a day that I forget. So really it's maybe once every two weeks
do I go a whole day and not remember to do it. More often maybe once a week I'll go all day and go
oh gee I didn't even take my supplements now it's four o'clock and I take them. So there's that
there's that. Is that the right thing to do? Is it better to stay regular? Yes I do believe so.
I think I feel better when I stay regular and sometimes when I'm feeling better that's what I do
start to forget things. So but again my situation is you know what I recommend is you're not
have your mind done. You can'ts are all the time. So I'm not thinking about my cancer as much as I
can possibly not think about your cancer. So I'm trying to keep my mind busy. I'm staying very active
and it's just a matter of forgetting for me. I would I would say that if a person is a
lion patient policy their supplements can have that's where policy their supplements can have great
benefit. So if you're trying to kill a biotoxin policy your supplements that's where that really
shurns. With a cancer that's a different that's a different story I wouldn't say policy is
is an important thing to do by any stretch of imagination. Next question seriously had on different
types of fasting that we've talked about multiple different types of fasting on our website and
our videos. I just wanted to kind of talk about it because several questions came in about that
in kind of like one little piece of a video here. So what are the different types of fasting?
A person could do a full water fast. That's what you usually think of the person is doing a fast.
So that means they're not eating anything. They're not drinking anything but water. So they're
on a water fast they can do historically do that for one two three four days. There's good and bad
to it. So if a person has cancer though remember what I've said about this we don't want to go
out of full water fast because after all the research shows that after 24 hours of full water fast
your IGF1 levels start to rise and that's not that that can be good for anti-aging things like I want to
just clean out be healthy and do the right thing but that's not what we want for our cancer patients.
So we don't want cancer patients to go on fasts longer than about 20 hours really.
Just to be safe. Our goal is to make sure that our IGF1 levels are dropping
that's one of the purpose of the fast for our cancer patient. So you're decreasing this one pathway
that we've spoken about a lot your K-ROS pathway so that it'll decrease growth and that's why you
want to go on a fast for our cancer patient you want to decrease growth. So the thought is well I'm
not going to eat so that my cancer won't be fed so I'm going to go on a 40 day fast. Jesus
didn't I can do it too. Well that's not going to be good for you really. Jesus wasn't dealing with
cancer at the time and he had different reasons for going out his fast. So for a cancer patient I would
not recommend to fast more than 20 hours. So we don't do water fasts here. Fasting mimicking diet
is another way to fast. So a fasting mimicking diet gives you all the benefits of a lug
water fast like a five day water fast but a fasting mimicking diet is you're still eating a very
specific scientifically developed number of calories and the type of calories each day for five days
where you'll get all the benefits of a five day water fast lowered IGF blood levels lowered K-ROS
lowered growth fasting mimicking diet is the biggest thing we promote as far as trying to get a
whole of a cancer that's growing rapidly. Do eat a five day FMD fasting mimicking diet. This it
comes in a kit and one kit will take you through the whole five days and yes you will be hungry
during those five days but you've got to follow the diet exactly the way it's laid out in this kit
and more information on that we have videos just on the fasting mimicking diet and a whole bunch of
information on our website on this. But that's the most recommended one that we use. Well I should say
really the intermittent or the time restricted fasting eating is really the most common one. We
really recommend this as beneficial for everybody and that is really picking a time during the day which
is your eating window. So in this little skew here it looks like between the 12 o'clock and 4 o'clock
this person is eating and then they're fasting for for 20 hours a day you know and then this is
their eating window. So it's many times that's what the referral is. What is my eating window? Well I
do this a lot. So I'm really good at not being hungry all day long. So if I come to work and I'm busy
taking care of patients writing things I don't even think of food and so I have no trouble after I've
done eating at 8 o'clock the night before and it's time to go to bed that not eating again until I get
home at at 6 o'clock. So typically my eating window is really from 6 to 10. And some people will say
well that's horrible because then you go to bed on a full stomach and that's not really the
best for weight loss and I'm probably you know a wonderful little testimony of that truth but it is
that's not what I'm doing it for. So I'm doing it to keep my IGF1 levels down keep my growth of cancer
down because I'm decreasing those metabolic pathways. So I'm getting the benefits of a fasting
mimicking diet doing this on a daily basis but I don't do it every day. So you would get the benefits
of a fasting mimicking diet if you did it daily. I don't do this every day. I only do it maybe three
times a week but that really helps me. Would a fasting mimicking diet be probably better and would
really lower those levels down? Yes. So I've done the FMD multiple times. That's five days. So
they recommend that you do it five days three months in a row. So one of the weeks of every month
you're doing the fasting mimicking diet and then you don't have to do it again for six months or a year.
We have some patients that will do this every every three months. We have some patients that will
do it every six months. I've done it since my since we introduced the FMD year and a half ago. I've
done it five times so I probably should do it again. So those are the really the three main types of
fasting. These two in the fasting mimicking diet and the time restricted eat or the two that we
recommend to most everybody and the time restricted eat is probably the easiest one to do of all of these.
It's just picking a window and once you get used to that you're holding to that window. Now we
allow our patients to take their supplements and everything in this window as well. So let's say you're
going to only eat as in this diagram between dude and four. Can I take my morning supplements?
Yes you can. So your supplements are very important. So you're taking your supplements in any time
you need to be taking your supplements. It's just that you're consuming food in that window time.
Okay so with that we will open it up for questions. I will unmute everybody and feel free to
share your feedback. I have a question. Dr. Connors this is Johnny Cosette.
I recently heard about some interesting information and you may have already heard about it but I
would just like to kind of throw it out to you as far as the cause for cancer and being exposed to
this toxin or it's called it's a fungus called scleridium rulfsi and some of the effects are
toxic blue cyanofilamentus bacterial I don't know and some of that stuff anyway. I was kind of
wondering if the fungal programs that you know I think I was given by the clinic. Does it cover
that type of fungus? It covers all the frequencies of fungi that are known. I have to look
on yours and get I'll make sure. I'll let you know if there isn't but I'm almost positive we put
sweepsets on yours. What? Which would cover anything in between there so you should be fine on
the fungal. If you want to run separate fungal programs you can run the ones that are already in your
the program under I think it'll be automatically under fungus. Yes sir. Okay.
Thank you very much. You bet. Dr. Conner. I'm still having a difficult time with my energy levels.
I wake up in the morning and need to go back and lay down about 45 minutes after I wake up which
doesn't fit in our lifestyle very well. I'm pretty sure it's an adrenal problem but it's about
1 o'clock in the afternoon start getting energy. I just don't know what else to do.
Okay so we really should probably run it what's called an adrenal stress test on you.
Which is the salivary test where you take your saliva sample four times in a 24 hour period
and then you can see that what's called the cortisol rhythm. Okay. So it's a very common test it
really can tell if your cortisol rhythm is just way out of whack then we know you're dealing with
a primary pituitary adrenal issue and then you could take real you know corrective measures on that.
Okay so just call up there and get it. Yeah I'll tell the girls we can pull it and get it ready for you.
Okay thanks. Yeah. Let's talk a little bit about that also so what are some reasons for fatigue
in a person with with any disease or with cancer so obviously a person can have fatigue with
cancer. The most common reason for fatigue with cancer would be if it is if it is you know growing
an active cancer is going to be just the cancer is just draining the person's energy so if the
person has concaxia meaning that the cancer is breaking down muscle and that would be evident in
visual. I don't have any muscles mass anymore or my strength is weeding and I'm losing
several pounds a week. So that's the definition of concaxia and with concaxia that's going to
drain your energy because your your cancer is just turning your muscle cells into glucose.
And then you can have fatigue depend on what type of cancer you have and what organs it's it's
reflexively affecting and like colon cancer you're not absorbing your nutrients as well that can
cause fatigue. Cancer in the abdominal cavity anywhere can reflect back to a decrease
adrenal function that can cause fatigue. So there's multiple reasons for that. Also what a person
is a person can have primary pituitary adrenal issues that's what was discussed
by our last question and that is just because of prolonged stress or any reason can affect the
pituitary adrenal access and then you just aren't getting the adrenal output at the time that you
should be that's why you do that cortisol rhythm test because you there should be a normal rhythm
cortisol secretion that should actually be highest at about about two o'clock in the morning
and then it drops down slowly at the end till the end of the day. So from a normal adrenal
function you have it should not be as far as energy-wise a person should be able to wake up and
get out of bed and have normal energy and then they can fatigue at the end of the day. So there's
different different issues with the adrenals that we'd want to look at with that function test.
Okay I'd mute everybody again any other questions. We're all good. All right well we'll get this
recording posted up and thank you for participating and again always email your questions in
if you have questions that come up to underscoretik at gmail.com and just put in the
sub title or the subject-lined zoom call question and we'll get to it. All right thanks a
bye-bye.